Bonjour à tous !
Si je vous demande de dessiner des branches d'arbres
vous allez sûrement faire quelque chose
qui ressemble à ce que fait mon petit frère.
Oui
Quand on a appris à dessiner
on avait déjà remarqué que...
il fallait faire une branche puis la diviser en deux
puis que chacune des branches se divisait
en branches plus petites, etc.
Léonard de Vinci, lui-même, avait établi à son époque
une relation entre le diamètre du tronc et
le diamètre des branches qu'il porte.
Et quand j'ai appris ça, ...
ça m'a sciée.
Mais vous ne vous êtes jamais demandé pourquoi on retrouve toujours plus ou moins cette forme ?
Un groupe de recherche interdisciplinaire
composé de bio-mécaniciens,
de physiciens des systèmes complexes,
d'éco-physiologistes des arbres.
(j'adore les mots de plus de trois syllabes)
Et donc ce groupe s'est intéressé
à la question suivante...
Et si la forme des arbres était juste le
résultat de la lutte contre le vent
et de la compétition pour accéder à la lumière.
Les chercheurs ont choisi de tester
leurs hypothèses par la modélisation.
Et ça donne ça !
Ouais ! Faut reconnaître qu'on est un peu loin
du dessin de mon petit frère.
Pour créer ces arbres virtuels, ce n'est pas si simple.
Les chercheurs doivent intégrer
tout un tas de connaissances,
en biologie, en mécanique et en météorologie.
Ils vont donner à ces arbres des paramètres
qui sont un peu comme leurs gènes.
Par exemple, avoir des feuilles larges et opaques
qui captent bien la lumière,
ou des branches solides,
ou être capable de faire pousser de nouvelles branches rapidement.
Et puis le modèle inclut deux règles
qui sont issues de deux découvertes récentes.
D'une part, la localisation des nouvelles branches qui
bourgeonnent dépend de la lumière reçue.
Et d'autre part, le diamètre des branches
est contrôlé par les effets du vent.
Et ça s'appelle la thigmomorphogénèse.
Bam ! Six syllabes !
Parfait !
Sauf que ...
tout ça ne suffit pas expliquer
la croissance d'un arbre dans une forêt.
Il manque un élément clé.
L'é-vo-lu-tion.
Oui !
Les paramètres ou les gènes
des arbres dont je vous parlais
ont une certaine variabilité à l'échelle d'une forêt.
Un arbre va avoir des branches plus solides,
l'autre va être plus sensible à la lumière.
Et certaines mutations peuvent
apparaître au cours de l'évolution
L'évolution est ensuite simulée sur  île virtuelle,
baignée de soleil et de vent.
Pourquoi une île ?
Non ! Pas parce que les chercheurs
rêvaient de partir en vacances.
Quoique !
Mais parce qu'on peut supposer qu'elle est isolée
et qu'elle ne reçoit pas de graines de l'extérieur.
Voici une représentation des différentes espèces sur une île forêt de vingt mille arbres.
Chacun des points représente un arbre.
Et la taille du point représente l'étendue de son feuillage.
Les couleurs correspondent
à des variétés d'arbres différentes,
donc avec des paramètres gènes différents.
Ce qu'on constate d'abord,
c'est une sélection naturelle,
enfin virtuelle du coup,
des arbres ayant les propriétés les
plus favorables à la survie.
Donc branches robustes, croissance rapide.
Et à la fin, on a plus que la variété
d'arbres représentée en vert.
Ah !  Et au cas où vous ne l'auriez pas remarqué,
vous venez de voir l'évolution d'une forêt
de vingt mille arbres,
pendant dix mille ans.
Rien que ça !
On peut aussi rentrer dans cette forêt virtuelle
et observer la structure des arbres.
Les chercheurs ont mis en évidence
que la compétition pour la lumière
va contrôler la division branches
et donner une forme fractale aux arbres.
Et ils ont montré, qu'il existe un lien entre opacité du feuillage et dimension fractale de l'arbre.
De son côté, la réponse au vent,
(pour rappel, thigmomorphogénèse, six syllabes)
influence l'évolution du diamètre des branches
Et en bonus, les chercheurs ont même montré
que l'on retrouve la loi de Léonard de Vinci
sur la taille des branches.
Dans un arbre, la somme des sections
des branches portées par un tronc
est égale à la section de ce tronc.
En tout cas, cette étude a montré
que le couple lumière / vent,
à lui-seul, permet de faire émerger
la forme, bien connue, des arbres d'aujourd'hui.
Voilà ! J'espère que vous avez apprécié ce sujet...
parce que moi en tout cas...
ça m'a bien branché.
Et surtout, n'oublie pas de t'abonner !